oh yo Fab ok yo à tous
Fab pour pour cette dernière journée
normalement du
ouais enfin je crois pas que ça puisse
durer plus non je crois pas non plus
mais bon qui c'est qui c'est est-ce que
ambulant peut revenir pour une super
finale où il te dit en fait non je suis
de retour je rejoue quoi bah pourquoi
pas en fait en même temps normalement
c'était le favori quoi donc
ça pourra donner une grande finale là
bon celle-là pour l'instant elle est un
petit peu à sens unique mais écoute ça
peut tourner imagine ça ne gagne cette
partie il y a plus qu'un point d'avance
ce petit coup de stress et c'est bon
jamais on ne sait pas Fab on ne sait
jamais oui on va dire c'est pas le seul
probable mais tout est possible tout est
réalisable non c'était parler au
téléphone et on pensait la petite
berlinoise e4-5 mais en fait non ça part
sur des quatre il refait G6 bah écoute
c'est vrai que ça arrive est venu au
combat alors
son nom
il est venu au combat oui mais j'ai vu
son interview d'après match hier
ou alors il a annoncé la couleur tu vas
être très solide il a ils lui ont dit
oui machin tu dois marquer un point un
point et demie demain nanani nanana lui
moi j'espère faire trois nuls enfin bon
là-bas
non mais il a bien raison
normal
il est très solide dès le début tu fais
une slave inverse
c'est un coup j'ai vu dans l'autre sens
avec des damakas pour t'empêcher de
reprendre du pion ça va l'énerver ça
en reprendre c'est prendre
BK
après bon quand il a pris il est mieux
en c3d2 quoi je sais mais bon tu es
quand même pleutre quoi tu as envie
en tout cas voilà bon alors ça arrive
qui a raison il essaye tout de suite de
jouer un truc un peu compliqué on ne
soit pas complètement symétrique et
surtout pas complètement théorique aussi
parce qu'hier il était nettement
derrière dans le dans le petit jeu
théorique j'ai envie de dire
donc il sort des sentiers battus
qui réfléchit immédiatement ouais c'est
qu'il y a bien gérer son temps
tout au long de ce match
c'est beau aussi oui il faut que je veux
vraiment faut vraiment que je fasse nul
quoi enfin après c'est beau aussi gagne
ah bah ça va encore plus vite mais
évidemment possible
je pense que les joueurs peuvent avoir
eu des consignes de range qui leur dit
bon les gars
stop faire nul trop vite
il va essayer de jouer jusqu'au bout ou
pas
difficile en fait
évidemment
l'organisateur il espère qu'il est
toujours beaucoup de combat mais le
problème en fait c'est que les joueurs
sont là pour gagner pas pour faire le
spectacle non non je sais mais genre
c'est propositions nulles un petit peu
intempestives est-ce que tu penses qu'il
a dit fin tu vois les gars si vous
pouviez un peu qu'est-ce que tu veux y
faire en fait soit tu mets des règles
avant de tournoi interdit aux nul en
moins de 30 coups interdit aux
proposition de nul tout court ou et puis
bah si annule c'est dans les positions
complètement nulles des finales qui sont
nuls quoi ou trois fois la répétition
enfin une position
là peut-être qu'il a pu dire un petit
mot mais
[Musique]
je veux dire enfin moi mais moi tu vois
que tu l'as commenté et qui m'a bien
qu'il y ait du combat et tout je veux
dire je suis dans la peau de saut dès
que je peux faire mieux que je fais nul
enfin en fait je veux juste gagner le
tournoi je prends mon argent je prends
mon titre et je suis content en fait
enfin mon but c'est pas de faire du beau
jeu c'est juste de gagner ça ça me fait
penser ben on parle souvent de rugby
mais comme moi au rugby quand je fais
match de l'Afrique du Sud enfin je suis
très énervé de leur jeu parce que
évidemment c'est pas le rugby qu'on aime
c'est pas flamboy mais bon ça existe ça
le mérite d'exister et on fait évoluer
les règles pour essayer de les limiter
mais il retrouve des marlouteries pour
pour jouer avec leur style etc avec
quelque part heureusement que pas tout
le monde fait le spectacle parce que
sinon ce face à créer un autre problème
j'ai envie de dire il y aurait pas
d'opposition de style quoi c'est ça tu
veux tu tu tu tu essayes d'être efficace
et bon bah là surtout quand tu as deux
points d'avance voilà après sauf
franchement son style il a fait des
rayanakas c'était pas évident parce que
Nathan était quand même grand favori
était en forme et c'est pas du tout
facile de l'éliminer sur un des
rencontres sur internet comme ça une
cadence en plus rapide donc grosse
prestation de saut après évidemment
c'est pas spectaculaire mais peu importe
enfin comme j'ai dit le but c'est pas de
faire le spectacle donc après nous
souvent on rigole machin ça me fait
marrer mais bon en soit il a bien raison
de faire ça et là il est là il a une
finale il mène de deux points bah qui
continue et bravo à lui c'est fini par
remporter le tournoi comme ça et j'ai
même envie d'aller plus loin Fab et te
dire que finalement hier sur sa deuxième
est parti avec les Blancs alors qui
menait déjà d'un point c'est lui qui a
ouvert le jeu en réalité en sacrifiant
la qualité si on réfléchit bien
complètement alors qu'il était pas
obligé d'ailleurs j'ai toujours pas
compris mais
en tout cas celui à porter bonheur et
voilà
il a peut-être senti une petite
fragilité en fait
probablement et bah c'était choisi
un choix payant de sa part mais j'ai
envie de dire là autant parfois on peut
le critiquer sur le fait qu'il ferme le
jeu autant là la quatrième partie bah il
fait nul avec les Noirs mais bon on a du
mal à lui demander plus une rapide et la
deuxième il était mieux avec les dents
j'ai toujours du mal à critiquer le
genre avec les Noirs quand il fait nul
rapidement parce que c'est ce que tu es
venu chercher et alors quand tu fais la
nul rapide avec les blancs dans la
berlinoise et que tu saches complètement
on peut dire bon on aurait préféré avoir
plus de jeu mais quand le joueur avec
les Noirs prend un légère avantage et
qui décide de gérer en prenant le demi
point il y a c'est quand même difficile
de enfin il obtient ce qu'il était venu
chercher quoi
de toute façon
en tout cas pour l'instant il gère bien
et donc il a choisi le A3 B4 en tout cas
pour rompre le clouage donc la lame
bouge il va reprendre les quatre du pion
bien sûr c'était pour ça qu'il a fait
tout ça c'est pas pour reprendre une
pièce il va mettre le fond B2
probablement après et développer
peut-être qu'il y a des dossiers 4 aussi
qui arrivera pour aller te regagner un
tempo sur la dame
mais en fait il va adapter selon la
structure qui en choisir si je joue avec
des 5 il fera autre chose peut-être bon
tu peux aller dans des deux ou on croit
mais peut-être direction C5 en fait dans
les deux cas là tu as un peu le choix
bon sûrement tu fais fouger deux déjà tu
rock et tu avisera après sur ton aile
dame j'imagine j'aime bien la position
des blancs personnellement cette prise
d'espace Fabien à 3 B4 elle est quand
même assez intéressante oui après
peut-être fougère ça va et je me dis
fougère deux il y a peut-être à 5 je
pensais exactement la même chose que toi
en même temps
que tu as B5 voilà donc plutôt que ces
trois du coup
dans la vue une option à l'adversaire et
cette dame en B6 je la trouve mal placée
en réalité
bon bah tu rentres à la maison en C7 tu
es quand même très exposé au fouet F4
autour 5 qui vont arriver donc en B6
c'est peut-être le moindre mal bien que
ce soit loin d'être parfait je pense
qu'il fait fouger de rock rapidement et
je pense aussi c'est jouer
instantanément D6 et rock ouais c'était
forcément mieux avec les Blancs ici
enfin c'est indiscutable oui plus
d'espace
[Musique]
mieux développer plus d'espace quand tu
vas faire fouger 5 tu menaceras faut
prendre M6 qui est des 5 qui est premier
avec le fou
pas ça va être blindé si tu as la
structure f2e 3D 4 contre le le pion
doublés
enlève les C5 au noir quoi donc tu vas
être fermé tu as une structure fixée et
en général tu peux donc échanger les
fous quand la structure est fixée ou
définie on peut dire peu importe le
vocabulaire employé mais quand il y a
pas de rupture qui peut ouvrir les fous
la turbine propose un enchaînement des 5
le truc c'est que sur D5 et il prend des
cinq et prends des 5 fous prends des 5
dames prends des 5 fous prends un il y
aurait fou le 3 à la fin et tout reprend
tu as envie de faire pour venir en D4
pourquoi pas
après le seul problème de dessin c'est
que tu fermes ton fou et tu ouvres
l'autre donc c'est quand même un choix
tu te mets en décape tu le bloques et
après tu es pas du tout obligé de faire
ça a l'air bien quand même oui oui
complètement
parce que tu prends tellement d'espace
sur les chéquiers et les pièces noires
vont être fatu gagne en fait des temps
en plus tu gagnes un temps ici tu vas en
gagner un deuxième ici tu vas mettre ta
tour en C1 tu vas peut-être en gagner un
troisième ici un moment donné tu auras
encore cavalier des cadres en regagner
un là enfin un moment donné tu as
commencé à faire un peu trop de temps
non tu vas tu vas tuer des temps sur
toutes les pièces noires en fait
en vrai ça dépend il n'a qu'une
philosophie de façon so à être accepté
comme il est et il fait fou B2 plus
pleutre bah viser la nul ça lui fait pas
peur
bah il y croit
il a raison
toujours le point levé
le début
c'était un peu déjà la fin là le combat
est à plein régime donc ça va
je demande s'il y a pas jouer un petit
coup comme H3 pour essayer de préparer
des 5 4 gagner le fou en force
et tu commences à rentrer un peu sur les
cases des 5 c'est 4 etc donc tu peux pas
ne rien faire avec les Blancs
c'est pas possible en fait il va falloir
que être un peu entreprenante quelque
chose
donc effectivement par fait le
dessinateur c'est un peu dommage et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que tu coaches des joueurs qui
ont l'intention de devenir enfin que
l'intention mais aussi le potentiel j'ai
envie de dire parce que l'intention
de toute façon si ils ont l'intention
mais qui peuvent pas toi tu es quelqu'un
de sincère non tu leur dis
ouais ouais non mais après je suis pas
un gars qui vient te dire j'ai envie de
devenir grand maître et que tu vois que
c'est pas possible tu
vas être difficile quoi
déjà on va essayer de faire des étapes
avant peut-être ou je sais pas mais non
alors en ce moment j'ai personne dans le
but est d'être grand maître après
[Musique]
disons en fait dans le mode où
j'entraîne
c'est un peu varié au début j'étais
plutôt accès au niveau donc soit au
niveau j'ai été préparateur et capitaine
équipe de France donc bon là maintenant
c'est très haut niveau j'ai eu des forts
jeunes vous voyez notamment une fille
qui est devenu championne du monde non
championne du monde
et puis c'était bien tu vois enfin un
titre de champion du monde c'est pas
rien c'est une chose c'est totalement
donc ça secoue j'ai eu un petit que je
suis pendant quelques années Clément
qu'une qui apparemment je l'avais elle
était viche champion d'Europe c'était
des moins de 12 ans là il vient de faire
sa première arme de maître il a 14 ans
là je le suis plus en ce moment en fait
mais je veux dire j'ai eu des choses
comme ça donc voilà j'ai aussi eu un
joueur
qu'on a commencé à travailler ensemble
est autour 2100 et devenu maître depuis
et bon là maintenant on a arrêté
maintenant qu'il émette c'était son
objectif
c'était voilà
donc voilà j'ai eu des gens comme ça et
puis en fait récemment il y a eu quelque
part un switch c'est à dire qu'il y a
une nouvelle population qui
s'intéressait aux échecs plus amateur
débutant autodidacte et je me suis un
peu spécialisé là-dedans on va dire
alors je reste ouvert pour que c'est au
niveau mais en fait je trouve ça
intéressant rafraîchissant était plus là
à transmettre partager la passion aussi
que de faire que des analyses de longues
enfin c'est autre chose on va dire et ça
me plaît bien voilà après l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre en même temps mais en ce
moment j'ai plus ce profil là voilà
et tu me coaches aussi en quelque sorte
à force de me parler tu me fais
progresser en quelque sorte on peut le
dire
on se fait progresser ensemble
mais bon c'est vrai que les fous tu sais
que j'en ai parlé à Vaki des fous devant
le furto
tout le monde sait en fait
oui mais
en fait le truc c'est que oui ben je
sais enfin je sais sans verbaliser et
donc c'est trop bien de verbaliser
d'avoir le concept clairement établi
il avait complètement en fait
évidemment
parler avec des joueurs forts ça fait
progresser c'est sûr tu parles avec du
backi du progresses à force de parler à
bah qui tu progresses
bah ouais ton truc des idées des
variantes des concepts etc parce que
tant bien et un coup je dirais pas trop
penser mais c'est quand même non une
colonne vertes tu te mets dessus quoi
plus logique
plus logique pour C1 après tu as
d'autres options mais c'est plus si ça
enfin les blancs sont plus si mieux
complexe
mais ouais après ce qui fait le plus
progresser c'est quand même le travail
personnel et tu vois c'est marrant parce
que je parlais avec Baki aujourd'hui
parce que j'en sais vu une petite heure
et je disais que j'avais en fait pas mal
il y a un truc que j'avais oublié dans
les trucs que j'ai lu quand les gens
m'ont demandé c'est pourquoi j'étais
devenu bon en finale
t'avais dit mais en fait j'ai oublié un
autre truc tu sais quand je m'occupais
du club d'échec là à Moscou ouais en
fait on avait acheté les livres pour le
club alors c'était des livres de
biographie des champions du monde et du
coup on avait capable en cas machin sur
moi les kids on en avait plusieurs et tu
sais comme souvent quand un club d'échec
t'as pas forcément grand chose à faire
quand les gens jouent tu tu dis un peu
moi je les lisais et en fait je disais à
chaque fois je dis aux gens que j'ai
progressé avec vored Ski et c'est vrai
mais j'ai oublié de dire que de manière
passive j'ai lu aussi ces bouquins et
qu'en fait à force en plus tu as les
anecdotes des parties etc et que à force
de les lire quand même si tu te
rappelles le truc genre par exemple la
fameuse finale à l'équipe capable en cas
avec le 3 contre 3 les tours le machin
et tout enfin tout ça en fait avec les
histoires autour tu les regardes tu les
refais tu machins et tout enfin plein de
trucs en fait ça devient maîtriser et ça
devient maîtriser sans faire exprès
parce que les livres sont passionnants
et jabakia oui [ __ ] j'ai oublié de
dire ça et puis du coup j'en discute
ensemble aujourd'hui je dis ah oui
[ __ ] j'ai complètement oublié j'en
parle jamais mais c'est libre en fait on
fait beaucoup progresser pas que par
leur contenu américains et comme c'est
écrit de manière journalistique et c'est
assez passionnant parce que tu as les
anecdotes pendant les parties les
machins et tout genre la partie
birdstein capable Blanca quand il fait
C4 là pour les pions pendantes on dit
oui tu as tous les grands met sur place
enfin les grands maîtres les joueurs top
du niveau je pense un coup de merde
c'est un con machin et que 3 jours après
en fait c'était vraiment très fin mais
de base je te dis oui bon il comprend
absolument rien c'est un débile bon peu
importe oui j'ai lu ces livres et tout
en fait fantastique mais en fait j'en ai
dans ma bibliothèque j'en ai plus en
russe aussi il m'a dit oui très bon
livre et du coup de fil en aiguille tu
vois c'est un contenu de bouquin que
j'ai lu qui m'a fait beaucoup progresser
que j'avais complètement oublié mais
j'ai envie de dire que tu vois quand je
vais te citer les trucs qui m'ont fait
le plus progresser dernièrement enfin
donc j'ai fait après en étant jeune
adulte toi en fait c'est que des trucs
que j'ai fait seul
d'ailleurs en fait
pour appuyer ça quand on me demande
quelle fréquence faut prendre des cours
ou quoi après bon déjà ça dépend de son
budget ou quoi mais même sérieusement je
dis c'est beaucoup mieux de faire un
cours tous les 15 jours et de travailler
soi-même entre les séances que de faire
un cours par jour et de rien [ __ ] en
fait tu es passif
donc oui ça c'est un très bon conseil il
faut travailler seul il faut lire faut
jouer il faut analyser et voilà et ça
c'est important et le deuxième truc à
dire ouais dans ta lecture passive ou
quoi en fait c'est un concept qui
passait pas exactement ça marche mais ça
marche dans tous les domaines tu as
quatre étapes en fait pour pour ta
propriété quelque chose bon début tu es
même pas conscient que ça existe
non tu sais pas que ça existe
mais que tu es incompétent après tu
commences à l'avoir mais tu dois
tellement y penser pour le faire que tu
maîtrises pas trop et un moment en fait
tu t'appropries la compétence et tu
penses même plus pas tu sais ça devient
plus pas inné pour le coup parce que tu
l'as appris en fait
tu cliques et en fait donc de lire de
faire tout ça comme tu l'as fait bah oui
évidemment ça te donne plus d'appropriée
tous ces concepts et quoi et voilà mais
ça marche en fait pas que pour les
échecs évidemment mais je dirais que
pour moi les livres
avec des anecdotes tu vas plus
journalistique où tu allais partir mais
c'est beaucoup plus marquant parce que
tu as le côté émotionnel et en fait un
livre d'échec plus rédur genre de voir
est-ce que je suis vraiment fait chier à
lire bon ça évidemment c'est bien de
progresser mais ça m'a vraiment fait
chier premier degré et en fait les
autres livres du coup j'ai passé plus de
temps et tu as des concepts qui me
restent même mieux parce que c'est plus
L une émotion quand tu as lu ça t'a fait
rire ou l'anecdote machin et du coup bah
là comme je te parlais de berger qui m'a
fait le plus rire en fait mais du coup
en fait je me rappelle très bien de la
position je rappelle très bien de la
partie je rappelle très bien du coup et
ça reste beaucoup plus tu vois je vais
pousser l'option comme il a fait tiens
en Détroit et tout ça veut dire que si
je pense qu'il y a un peut-être des gens
qui aiment mieux les livres théoriques
pure et durs et peut-être que pour
d'autres personnes les livres un peu
semi journalistique ou tu as beaucoup
d'analyses d'échecs sérieuses aussi
dedans mais mais qui sont entremêlés
d'anecdotes un peu marrantes un peu
intéressante un peu cool ça ça peut être
un bon médium de travail aussi quoi non
mais complètement en plus la mémoire
souvent elle marche avec d'autres
d'autres associations
et ça peut être avec le goût les odeurs
tu vois enfin c'est plus facile d'avoir
des émotions exactement et où notre zone
du cerveau qui a marché en même temps
mais d'ailleurs souvent en fait tu vas
mieux te rappeler quand on va te dire un
détail ouais mais tu te souviens à ce
moment tu m'avais dit ça mais ah oui
complètement pas juste l'information
brute et donc effectivement être écrit
comme ça ça peut être plus parlant et ça
les prolon pour beaucoup de gens
donc c'est pas mal c'est plutôt bien et
c'est très russe en fait de mettre pas
mal de textes d'ailleurs même carpov
quand il analysait ses parties c'était
beaucoup de textes et peu de variantes
en fait ah ils adorent je veux faire ci
je veux faire ça je comprenais le CASE
nanani nanana etc mais
on en discutait avec Baki on disait
malheureusement tu vois c'est le genre
de ces livres en russe là si tu voulais
les faire traduire ou quoi c'est le
genre de livre qui marcherait absolument
pas parce que maintenant les gens je
sais pas ils veulent des livres
d'exercices de machins de de stratégie
et tout alors que juste à prendre par
les champions avec des anecdotes cette
époque et tout je trouve c'est tellement
bien
bah en fait peut-être un problème
générationnel enfin c'est dommage en
fait mais
qu'est-ce que tu es là ou
je sais pas tu vas un peu plus tout tout
cuit tout de suite puis de prendre le
temps et aussi genre je sais pas moi je
suis assez choqué de parler avec des
gens qui sont plutôt forts d'échec mais
mamie ils sont incapables de me citer
des champions du monde d'échec
moi je savais à 8 ans en fait j'étais
très heureux de lire les magazines de
mon père après toi tu es aussi
complètement fou tu faisais des petits
tours de France avec des GT bon mais oui
mais bon c'est normal
de connaître tous les champions du monde
bah ouais mais genre ok habitants tu es
pas obligé mais je veux dire c'est
intéressant c'est important de connaître
l'histoire de ton jeu de ton sport et
dommage alors ça empêche pas d'essayer
de bien jouer ou quoi mais de pas savoir
qui c'est ninjovic ou lui il a pas été
champion du monde mais genre c'est un
grand nom ou quoi c'est bizarre quoi
c'est juste bizarre ouais
bah c'est que toi qu'une culture en fait
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus intéressant
mais en tout cas
j'oublie toujours de les citer comme
trucs qui m'ont fait progresser parce
que c'est des livres moins technique
machin et du coup même naturellement tu
les cites moi puis vont peut-être aussi
parce qu'ils ont pas été traduit tout
bêtement mais du coup voilà
l'utilisation de ce stream donc
ceux qui sont présents avec nous vous
avez un bon conseil
en fait les parties aujourd'hui de haut
niveau c'est juste que tu as les plans
main de Capablanca et c'est juste
comment réaliser ses plans là et puis
après au milieu on met plein d'embûches
pour réaliser les plans mais en fait je
sais pas du coup je philosopher un peu
tout seul là comme aujourd'hui je me je
me reposais ou quoi et je me disais en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que tu
as plein de gens qui ont du mal à
calculer je vois tu as beaucoup de
problèmes là
que ce soit même envie de son long
jusqu'à 2002 je dirais et en fait c'est
juste que tu as plein de gens qui ont du
mal à calculer parce qu'ils ont pas les
lignes directrices des plans
fondamentaux
que tu dois réaliser et du coup c'est
plus dur de d'éliminer les coûts
déjà faut savoir dans quelle direction
tu vas et après tu calcules pour tu peux
te tromper mais déjà choisir les bons
candidats
faire le filtre des coups qui
appartiennent à la position déjà c'est
le gros du travail après faut calculer
pour faire le bon choix et pas se
prendre de quoi intermédiaire etc etc ça
se bon c'est encore autre chose mais
l'un dans l'autre déjà c'est bien
d'aller dans la bonne direction et pas
de calculer pour calculer dans tous les
sens n'importe comment
je remarque souvent quand je joue sur
chestcom aussi quand tu montes là au
niveau quand tu commences à jouer que
des grands maîtres en fait sont et des
grands maîtres et qui sont chauds en
calcul en fait qui sont bons dans tout
en fait ils ont tout le temps les coûts
donc ils te jouent toujours les coups
main les plans main plus bon les autres
passer les ouvertures etc c'est je sais
pas c'est neuf coup sur 10 semaines et
le coup ils font la diff il faut être
surprennent c'est qu'ils vont réussir à
faire marcher un plan que tu pensais
qu'il pouvait pas faire marcher grosso
modo
et quand tu joues le niveau un peu en
dessous tu vois des mecs qui sont en
2007 sur cheesecom 23 23 50 en long
générale ils peuvent te battre et tout
parce qu'ils sont bons en tactique aussi
enfin je parle de ceux qui sont bons
glisser et que du coup ils sont
dangereux mais il leur manque quand même
beaucoup d'idées main au passage je
trouve beaucoup plus
de toute façon selon ton vélo tu as des
points faibles donc c'est pas parce que
tu es 2003 c'est pas soit un problème de
stratégie soit un problème de tactique
c'est un problème quelque part qui a pas
de bons partout non mais je vais dire
par là que quand tu es bombers
même si tu es 2003 tu es forcément bon
un tactique à partir d'un certain niveau
mais j'ai l'impression que la différence
avec ceux qui sont après 2009 par
exemple de 1900 c'est stratégiquement il
y a plus d'erreurs c'est tout le temps
mail et tactiquement c'est des monstres
alors que le niveau en dessous 2007
c'est généralement des très bons
tacticiens c'est pas tout le temps le
cas mais généralement mais
stratégiquement c'est un peu en dessous
quoi généralement
je me mets dans la catégorie des gens
qui sont un peu en dessous alors je sais
pas ils sont tactique ou en stratégie
mais c'est un peu en dessous dans les
deux secteurs on va dire mais je dois
dire qu'à partir d'un moment tu sens que
il y a tout qui devient naturel en fait
et du coup ils sont d'autant plus fort
en calcul parce qu'ils éliminent
d'autant plus les mauvais coups
donc ils ont le face à un mélange en
fait
il y a deux coups de sang nous poser la
question de savoir si le cas de gagner
le foot
dessiner si tu te souviens de la
position
toujours est-il donc il y a eu des
échanges bon bah saut tiens bien sa
position il fait pas grand chose mais
pour l'instant tout est tout est en
ordre
il va faire nul en fait
il est là pour ça bien parti pour
après le truc c'est que les pions à 4 à
5 sont faibles réciproquement dire que
le kb6 TA placard mais nous on aura le
feu c'est trois qui tapera 5
donc on va tous les deux si mobiliser
des pièces par là et on peut les changer
aussi en plus
en cas de besoin
mais ouais non lire l'histoire des
échecs ça rend passionnant il y a pas
assez de livres comme ça enfin en tout
cas c'est dommage que ce soit plus les
livres qui soient les mains quoi
c'est les gens n'aiment plus lire ce
type de livre
non mais en fait ce qui fait recette
c'est
les ouvertures
c'est on te vend une méthode ou un truc
tu es un fantastique avec moi vous allez
apprendre 6 si ça machin mais en fait
c'est tellement un long cheminement
qu'en fait toute façon c'est pas en
lisant un truc c'est pas en faisant un
coup enfin même 10 cours en fait
ou un stage moi j'en organise tu vois
donc de toute façon je le vends jamais
comme dans 10 ans venez faire un stage
vous allez repartir une année 200.0 en
fait c'est utile c'est bien parce que
vous voulez apprendre des trucs ça va
mais en fait ça sera pas autosuffisant
il va falloir travailler et ça va pas
être en un claquement de doigt ça va pas
être en trois jours
c'est long en fait mais je sais pas en
fait tout est long
je préfère les exos mais les exos c'est
bien en fait si genre tu fais un sport
et de progresser voilà tu vois bon moi
je suis dans le tennis là mais je veux
dire ça fait trois ans quoi que je
prends les cours ou quoi mais ça va pas
vite mais
3 ans c'était terrible non mais c'est
comme ça en fait petit à petit pas faire
de fautes etc etc faut voilà faut du
temps de toute façon aux échecs à partir
d'un d'un monde donné tu as aussi un
truc que les joueurs amateurs
sous-estiment je dirais réellement c'est
qu'en fait c'est que un jeu de calcul
après
à partir d'un certain niveau comme ta
question c'était comment devenir grand
maître tu vois
un moment donné c'est que du calcul en
fait
disons pour devenir grand maître il faut
que
toutes les bases et qu'en plus calcule
bien mais je veux dire que quelques
progressé en calcul est plus important
que progrès enfin calculer ouverture et
largement plus important que stratégie
cette stratégie
normalement un moment tu l'as en fait
enfin c'est plus le moment de la
travailler non mais c'est pas très dur
ce serait très étonnant d'avoir ce
niveau de visée grand maître et
stratégiquement être un plot quoi mais
bon
et on nous demande si quand tu es
amateur ça sert à rien ça sert parce que
c'est pour te faire prendre les bons
réflexes car c'est comme si t'as jamais
bah tiens je reprends les grosses du
tennis c'est quand même bien qu'on
t'explique comment tenir ta raquette la
prise coulera la prise revers la prise
pour servir elle a pris fin mais après
il va falloir que tu fasses des trucs
tout seul et puis peut-être que tu
ailles faire un peu de de salle pour
pour ta futé ou des choses comme ça et
ça de toute façon on va pas te la faire
faire pour toi quoi en fait c'est à toi
d'aller faire tes footing ou quoi si tu
le fais pas je peux pas courir pour toi
en fait pour les échecs je peux pas je
peux pas calculer à ta place je peux
t'expliquer ce que je veux quasiment
jusqu'à ce noir bon fou mauvais fou E40
les ouvertures mais les exercices il
faut les faire quand même
le calcul faut le faire et quand il faut
se forcer à calculer faut pas toucher
les pièces faut pas jouer les exercices
sans avoir calculé jusqu'au bout et ça
c'est l'élève de le faire enfin je peux
le motiver je peux avoir un discours
derrière allez c'est très bien nanana je
te donne un plan de travail pour la
semaine prochaine fait si ça mais après
s'il le fait pas mais il le fait pas en
fait mais en fait à un moment donné
enfin quand je sais pas à 24 24 50 on va
dire parce que ça à peu près ça le
niveau dont on parle là
j'ai l'impression qu'en fait c'est le
travail personnel il est vraiment
beaucoup plus important encore parce que
tu comme tu le disais en fait quand vous
êtes plus débutant ou quoi il y a plein
de trucs à vous expliquer qui sont pas
intuitif qui sont pas faciles forcément
à prendre etc mais une fois que tu as 24
en fait c'est que tu es plus gros défaut
c'est probablement quand même le calcul
et les ouvertures
en gros parce que 24 24 50 en fait tu
gères la stratégie déjà bah normalement
oui enfin suffisamment en tout cas
normalement toi
qui sont très talentueux dans une partie
du jeu et qui comprennent pas grand
chose à une autre partie du jeu mais la
plupart du temps ça va juste aller
donc c'était par rapport à ça mais après
quand on est complètement amateur au
contraire je dirais que les cours en
fait
jusqu'à ce niveau là ça peut toujours
t'aider en fait
on va dire je vois le prof comme un
guide quelqu'un qui t'aide à faire des
choses et qui donne la direction mais
faut faire le travail par soi-même quoi
qu'il en soit c'est toujours mieux
d'être suivi mais c'est bien enfin je
veux dire mais même quand tu as une
époque j'avais un peu à la salle je suis
content d'avoir deux trois conseils
qu'on me dise ouais fais plutôt de ça
cette machine faites intensif et
entendre ça mais après ça de le faire
enfin c'est cool d'avoir les conseils
qu'on me dise après je dois faire si je
fais pas chez moi bouffer des chips et
je l'ai fait c'est pas la preuve c'est
pas la preuve du coach ça non mais je
leur parle à couille à Piaf de toute
façon là à partir de ce niveau là comme
c'est le calcul le truc principal à
travailler ben après je vois même
muretas mais demander de lui donner des
cours entre guillemets dans un moment
donc il est beaucoup plus fort que moi
il a 400 points de plus alors attention
les cours de Mythas ça consistait à lui
trouver des exercices et à force à
chercher en fait grâce extraordinaire
parce qu'en fait ils sont foutait
complètement l'objectif c'était juste
d'être devant l'ordi de lui [ __ ] la
position de lui interdire de se lever
parce que ça le faisait chier il y
arrivait pas tout seul il réfléchir et
c'est tout en fait donc en fait je vais
qu'à partir d'un moment donné
pour progresser en fait c'est ça c'est
juste ça sort comme un con devant un
truc qui faire des exos parce que avec
Fab on fait plus du tout bah moi j'ai
pas une race assis mais je l'ai fait
pendant un moment bien sûr
[Musique]
et c'est ce qu'il faut
mais en fait déjà avoir des comptes à
rendre c'est bien mais je veux dire même
voilà je sors encore du 4 des échecs
mais quand bien même tu dois aller voir
un diététicien diététicienne ou quoi par
exemple en fait moi j'ai déjà fait quoi
du coup je sais enfin on fait noter un
peu tes habitudes on te dit ouais bah ça
sera bien changé si on est ça non non et
après en fait il retourne une fois de
son temps mais en fait tu as des comptes
à rendre quelque part tu as pas envie
d'y aller à dire ah ouais j'ai bouffé
que de la merde tu as envie de dire
ouais tu as vu j'ai bien suivi j'ai fait
ça et en fait tu aurais pas de
contraindre en fait c'est pas si dur une
fois que tu as fait la première séance
en gros tu as ton planning tu sais ce
que tu dois manger tu peux faire ça tout
seul mais le fait d'avoir des comptes à
rendre tu vas plus facilement suivre ça
bien sûr d'être livré à toi même de dire
ouais je sais mais bon demain allez
c'est bon ce soir ben ouais et voilà et
là donc c'est pareil pour les échecs par
exemple le fait que tu sois là pour myta
ça veut dire bah vas-y tu te lèves pas
tu cherches la position et allez quoi
bah lui il serait tout seul il sera
qu'il devrait faire mais
une demi-heure que je cherche j'en ai
marre vas-y je fais autre chose
et c'est ça en fait de truc là
mais en réalité à partir d'un certain
niveau c'est quand même ça qui te fait
progresser
c'est pour ça que toi ta cuite et que
moi j'ai même pas essayé en fait
parce que nous on est des tels comme
dirait vlades
bon du coup on n'a pas énormément parler
de la partie mais en fait c'est pas
passé grand chose donc
il y arrive il a bien toutes les changer
il y a cavalier fou chacun et plus que
quatre pions symétrique en plus il va il
va se diriger tranquillement vers la nul
un peu trop de pions sur noir à mon goût
mais oui ça va passer
H4 mais bon étant donné que tu as décalé
F4 qui rôde pour les
rh55
il y a plusieurs moments dans la partie
ou même là il aurait pu complexifier la
finale ou quoi mais
tranquille donc je sais pas c'est
intéressant ce qu'on racontait pour les
cours pour tout ça mais globalement non
c'est utile les cours mais c'est aussi
utile et primordial encore plus de
travailler soi-même donc les deux
peuvent se compléter et il faut les deux
pour pour progresser voilà
de gagner
c'est un bon conseil ça vous pouvez
avoir quand vous êtes devant niveau
matériel et changer les pièces mais pas
les pions
juste un coup de plus par exemple à la
fin ou vous ne pourrez plus gagner
un petit défi
bah voilà c'est ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs
nul facile sans je sais pas passer grand
chose dans cette partie non non mais bon
bah écoute
donc il sort approche il a plus qu'un
point à marquer pour gagner cette grande
finale
il aura deux fois les Noirs donc faudra
faire un peu attention et une fois les
blancs encore bon on a vu qu'avec les
mains c'était bien géré on verra la
prochaine avec les Noirs ce qui va se
passer pour l'instant les deux premières
il a pas du tout été mis en danger et
donc Sarine de venir avec peut-être une
nouvelle ouverture et si autre chose
parce que ça a pas trop marché ce qu'il
a fait jusque là tiens il y a une
expérience
devant un goban et puis tu vas devenir
plus fort mais oui c'est pareil aux
échecs en fait si tu t'es assis tu
calcules tu machins
tu progresses
toute façon il y a pas de mystère
regarde même là nous en commentant les
parties on en regardant et tout ça nous
fait un
c'est ridicule en terme de progrès par
rapport à ce qu'on pouvait faire si on
travaillait vraiment mais gère à force
de suivre un tour avec candidats un
deuxième un troisième un quatrième et
partie de Maxime il resa machin nanani
nanana les analyses le matin et tout bah
au final regarde même des fois quand on
discute de position on est au courant de
certains trucs qu'on aurait jamais su si
on les analysait pas toutes en fait
en vrai de vrai
les seuls battles tout ça quand même
mais ouais il y a que ça pour progresser
mais bon après à quoi ça sert aussi ça
la question en fait pourquoi tu joues
c'est ça le plus important c'est la
question à laquelle il faut répondre
à la position qui drone de Cornetto ah
bah oui genre de cavalier 3 pions machin
de Vaiana
enfin bon je le sais ce que j'avais des
trucs à Cornetto mais bon est-ce que ça
m'a fait progresser oui est-ce que ça me
casse les couilles oui enfin
facile même pas pourquoi je sais ça en
fait rien que le fait le savoir je me
demande pourquoi tu vis en fait
c'est terrible de savoir que deux tours
cavaliers qu'on détourne de Tours si tu
as trois pions plus sur la droite c'est
égal enfin pourquoi tu sais ça en fait
ouais c'est beau d'être quasiment énervé
de savoir un truc comme ça
je suis rentré
ben des fois tu sais parce que tu sais
oui mais bon enfin pourquoi tu as appris
ça dans ta vie enfin bon on se la
montrer et ben tu étais là à ce
moment-là en fait j'aurais pu ne pas
être là en fait et ne pas le savoir bon
j'aurais eu l'esprit beaucoup plus
tranquille quoi enfin
mais bon au final
l'accumulation de petits trucs comme ça
que tu connais ça te fait progresser au
bout d'un moment
de savoir des choses ça aide à mieux
juger donc à rentrer ou pas rentrer dans
un type de position il se fait gagner du
temps de calcul c'est gagner de
l'assurance etc
enfin moi plus avant et toi pendant plus
longtemps que moi mais après on a
surtout bossé le calcul pour être fort
enfin fort
on n'est pas très fort quoi mais c'est
surtout le calcul après quand même ouais
puis
de toute façon la motivation compte
beaucoup
je suis à peu près sûr que je connais
plus de choses maintenant qui a 10 ans
mais je pense que je lui ai 10 ans
parce que tu avais envie aussi c'est ça
la motivation compte beaucoup
mais je vois tu vois moi qui est plus
rien foutu pour le calcul mais
réellement plus rien foutu depuis que
j'ai 18 ans j'ai plus fait un exercice
de calcul quoi non mais le fait que tu
joues beaucoup ça te force en fait non
je sais mais je vais t'imagine que
pendant 17 ans sans rien avoir fait on
en a tellement bouffé du calcul à la con
on a tellement fait tellement fait
tellement fait que ça reste en fait
mais j'ai jamais dit que j'ai au Cap
d'Agde enfin j'ai jamais annoncé j'ai
jamais été inscrit j'ai toujours dit que
j'irai pas en fait donc c'était pas la
peine de me chercher quoi
non mais le calcul c'est quand même
spécial que ça parte pas parce que
effectivement ça pourrait partir
non mais ça part mais pas complètement
ça revient vite en fait tu as la méthode
et le bon réflexe tu sais comment
calculer c'est important déjà
en fait nous on nous a toujours obligé
par exemple regarde je prends l'exemple
d'un de nos potes Mehdi par exemple
un très bon pote c'est un ami Mehdi donc
on peut se permettre mais
dis calcule pas en fait quand tu vois
moi je pourrai pas jouer une partie
d'échec comme Mehdi
en fait il est resté aux échecs plaisir
mais faites moi je peux pas enfin
j'aurai un blocage mental en fait c'est
juste je ne peux pas jouer comme ça
ouais ben je sais enfin et pourtant il
est pas il est pas moins fort que moi
mais il y en a à peu près le même niveau
non mais en fait je suis hyper il s'en
fout il a pas envie quand tu vas jouer
pour gagner mais il préfère faire une
belle partie amusante et au pire hyper
mais donc partir amusante il va
sacrifier il a attaquer ah bah bien
défendu j'avais pas vu bravo que de
faire des parties comme ça et faire nul
ou gagner à la fin non mais je veux dire
par là que je voulais parler ça par
rapport à l'entraînement et tout ça tu
as comme nous on est un peu la même
formation ça bon en jeune etc moi enfin
comme je dise après j'ai arrêté fais pas
continuer mais en fait enfin moi je me
rappelle mes entraîneurs Murta etc en
fait tu jouais comme ça tu te faisais
défoncer après la partie même si tu
gagnes en fait rien à [ __ ] t'as pas
calculé tu es une merde donc ça c'est
toujours été enfin c'est la base
vas-y montre quelqu'un en fait tu vois
il a toujours eu je m'en fous en fait
non mais je comprends mais je veux dire
aussi que
je disais dans le truc ouais je voulais
dire ouais voilà c'était ça et je
voulais dire qu'en fait de t'avoir forcé
des petits de tout le temps à cette
rigueur de calcul et tout et qu'on
qu'était entraîneurs te fasse chier et
tout depuis gamin bah quand même ça sert
à quelque chose
en fait mais le mauvais côté c'est quand
même on peut pas jouer pour s'amuser
ah bah non c'est impossible moi je peux
pas m'amuser ouais c'est pas ça existe
pas en fait
et genre en fait là je dis que enfin
c'est c'est une très bonne chose pour
essayer de faire mieux possible c'est
une mauvaise chose dans le sens où là
j'aimerais bien les faire des tournois
on m'en foutant complètement mais tu
peux pas mais je sais mais quand je
préfère ne pas jouer en fait du coup
mais c'est chiant j'aimerais bien aller
jouer et au pire bah je perds je perds
et on s'en fout ben mentalement je
comprends très bien ça je peux le dire
et j'aimerais être comme ça mais en fait
mon cerveau rejette quoi et exactement
le même problème que toi quand j'ai
repris là que j'ai fait mes 11 parties
c'est impossible même en ayant arrêté de
jouer en longue machin pendant 14 ans
j'ai pas joué tu te remets devant en
échiquier tu te dis bon bah mon cerveau
il a nettoyé ça enfin c'est pas ça fait
14 ans que j'ai pas joué ça j'ai
commencé à 7 ans j'ai joué jusqu'à 17
jouer 10 ans et après je fais 14 ans de
pause donc j'ai fait plus de pause
que d'année où je jouais donc
en fait ça repart c'est pareil c'est que
tu es obligé de tout calculer tu veux
pas jouer de coup au hasard enfin c'est
terrible en fait
et ça s'arrête jamais donc c'est dommage
enfin c'est bien et c'est dommage c'est
bien dans le sens où si tu veux essayer
de jouer au mieux possible c'est dommage
dans le sens où un moment quand tu es
pas pro et que tu as le droit de je pour
t'amuser je peux pas
et voilà donc quelque part la prochaine
vidéo est pas mal parce qu'il pourra
jouer toute sa vie comme ça
des grands maîtres une fois de temps en
temps avec des belles parties des fois
perdre avec moi un bon parce que c'est
pas passé cette fois là c'est pas grave
il se fait plaisir quoi alors que du
coup en bide sont rapides tu te fais
quand même kiffer parce que tu as ce
truc qui marche quand même tout le temps
parce que c'est un truc automatique et
inné en fait
mais en fait c'est que tu calcules le
maximum et tu peux pas tout calculer
donc bon ben tu cliques un peu quoi tu
gères ton temps et tu essayes de
calculer quand tu peux et là tu t'amuses
encore mais en longue en fait sinon je
crois que tu peux plus t'amuser
et quand tu le laisses tu t'en veux
tellement
c'est très simple
ça devient enfin je veux dire une dans
le sens où tu as tellement travaillé que
en fait du coup c'est un truc sympa ça
devient
en fait on t'a appris en toi en fait
c'est fini c'est ton cerveau il est fait
pour faire ça tu t'assieds tu calcules
comme une merde
tu es obligé en fait
tu ne peux pas enfin genre je joue un
dimanche machin une partie à la con en
équipe j'en ai absolument rien à [ __ ]
et non faut que je me mette en PLS comme
une merde à calculer tout fin alors que
je veux juste en fait de base
c'est une maladie
mais par contre si tu veux devenir grand
maître c'est obligé ça
tu peux pas faire ça en fait
c'est très rare
oui mais ça veut dire que tu es grand
maître à 17 ans en fait si tu peux faire
sans faire ça
c'est qu'en fait tu es tellement fort et
ça va tellement vite que tu as même pas
besoin de te l'imposer enfin je sais pas
comment dire
un mec comme
[Musique]
je sais pas des gens qui n'ont pas
l'impression de forcer trop quoi
genre
quoi
franchement vous êtes en évites et tu as
pas un son qui forçait comme un fou quoi
et c'est ce qui lui permet de continuer
maintenant à cet âge là et de toujours
rester compétitif alors je sais plus si
c'est Vlad qui lui a parlé ou gris
tchouc ou quoi mais je sais que j'ai
cette discussion avec quelqu'un très
fort et il m'a dit en fait ah non de son
travail c'est déjà 2600 en fait c'est
beaucoup enfin c'est c'est beaucoup trop
en fait
il travaille toujours c'est ça le truc
mais
quand il était jeune là qui jouait ses
parties tempo
non mais ça va tellement vite c'est une
question de vitesse en fait là c'est
maso sont cachés c'est déjà j'aime ouais
mais vas-y en fait vous rendez pas
compte il calcule vraiment beaucoup en
fait juste c'est pas son point fort mais
il faut quand même des choses quoi
c'est pas son point fort pas son point
fort pour son niveau mais sinon il
calcule quand même très bien Amazon non
mais en plus ça le fait chier
il aime bien il calcule plus mais maso
il voit la beauté du jeu différemment il
aime le côté très stratégique les belles
finales machin son but c'est pas de
lancer des balles des attaques et
d'aller enfin s'il y a l'attaque qui va
le faire mais en soit tu lui demanderas
la partie parfaite je pense c'est
il domine il place bien ses pièces il
crée une faiblesse il rentre dans la
finale qui connaît nanana et te bats à
long terme mais c'est ça pour lui le
kiffe Mathieu tu demandes ça une belle
partie il y a plutôt de m'attendais une
attaque de maths donc c'est deux
manières de voir la beauté du jeu
différemment et peu importe mais donc
ces deux approches aussi un peu
qui m'a fermé d'ailleurs c'est que j'en
ai bien joué avec le style de Mathieu et
rock opposer les machins l'initiative et
tout mais en fait les ordis et la
théorie ça ferme vraiment parce qu'en
fait quand à ce style là toutes les
ouvertures qui amènent ces positions là
en fait les mecs qui peuvent te réciter
25 coups d'ordi à être complètement
gagnant si tu connais pas
ça a quand même un peu fermé ce style ce
truc là
en plus de ça la théorie tu es fermé en
fait non non
dans les années 70-80
trucs c'est en plus quand tu fais des
blits c'est que c'est sur internet il y
a pas un enjeu démesuré donc comme c'est
pas quelque chose qui va lui faire très
plaisir de calculer de base il va un peu
la joie légère
il va beaucoup plus calculer si c'est
parti contre pour le vélo
[Musique]
sur les tactiques pour moi c'est un
théoricien bon ben Mathieu c'est un gros
tacticien de base enfin man oui c'est un
peu non mais théoricien technicien
calcul ça a toujours été un bon joueur
de calcul je me rappelais jeune il
calculé fort et calculait et il
attaquait enfin je veux dire
je sais plus il est battu je sais pas
quel grand maître qui appelle jeune
grosse partie d'attaque sur
sur la Benoni les feuilles battre bélier
2005 je suis plus par là tu vois quand
il avait 17 ans
et du coup il était jeune il était
encore bon quoi il devait avoir un peu
plus il va avoir presque 20 Matthieu
bah je sais plus comment ça cette partie
contre
mais c'est un style plutôt comme ça en
fait plutôt mais Mathieu je me rappelle
que pour les catégories d'âge et tout ce
qui est un peu en dessous un peu au
dessus je me rappelle que c'était un des
rares qui calculait vraiment mieux que
moi
je compte pas les top top là dedans
évidemment je compte les gens qui
étaient un peu dans notre range de
niveau tu vois c'était vraiment celui
qui calculait plus vite que moi
calculez bien
je pense je sais pas si calculait mieux
que toi ou pas
je sais pas
mais
tous les deux
mais Mathieu
de ma faute
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
et il a quand même toujours eu cette
passion quand même pour les ouvertures
et tout ça
[Musique]
même jeune donc c'était les deux en fait
c'était son là dessus qu'il a joué mais
après chacun son style de jeu tu vois
c'est comme un mec au tennis je vais
faire ça laisse voler tu vas bien
travailler sa voler il va bien
travailler son service et puis il va
monter et puis voilà [ __ ] d'autres
c'est plus des mecs qui vont vouloir
jouer fond de cours ou je sais pas après
chacun son style quoi c'est pas Mathieu
le placement de pièces c'était pas trop
son truc par contre
mais je suis pas sûr qu'elle est
beaucoup d'autres en fait
dans les jeunes de notre génération
d'après peut-être d'Aki mais tu vois on
jouait pas avec lui il y avait marie
aussi
dans la même catégorie je peux te dire
que
Marie c'était ça allait très très vite
aussi
Marie de toute façon on a fait une belle
carrière là bon maintenant elle me lever
le pied
c'était c'était quelque chose
mais
après je sais pas par rapport à Mathieu
j'ai du mal à jauger mais Mathieu
c'était moi j'étais assez impressionné
impressionné Mathieu avec ça
[Musique]
c'était le sens du dynamisme mais sinon
il était vraiment meilleur que moi dans
ses positions là c'était le truc où je
jouais bien donc c'est pour ça que je me
rappelle fin c'est pour ça que ça
m'avait autant marqué j'en ai absolument
rien à [ __ ] aussi mais mais c'est pour
ça que je me rappelle vraiment parce que
tu vois c'est un truc où j'étais bien
ouais donc tu crées pas grand monde et
là tu dis merde il y a mieux quand même
ouais et puis bon après j'ai joué mvl et
j'ai compris que bon il y avait juste
une limite ADN quoi je sais pas comment
dire en fait c'est que là bon
[Musique]
pour ceux qui ont pas
un rêve qui ont pas le rêve mais qui
calculait très très bien Marie pour
mais oui Mathieu tu es ouais un peu
différemment contre lui c'était pas
possible de
si c'est toi qui attaque pourquoi pas
mais fallait pas te faire attaquer
toujours
en fait
c'est beau quoi cricore en fait il est
vraiment tombé dans le Guetta quoi
il va nous détester mais plus jamais
vouloir rien faire avec nous et dire oui
bon ils m'ont envoyé ce con une fois il
m'a défoncer mec non et en fait c'est
marrant bah qu'il a réalisé sacrifice de
pièces contre
malin comme truc en fait
un truc de
blitzer il se prend une [ __ ] de
nouveautés
il était démoli à la fin du truc quoi
enfin du coup pour prendre est-ce que
tout ça ouais bah on discuter tout ça
pour discuter de en tout cas tout le
point commun tu vois quand on cite les
gens qu'on connaît qui sont grands
maîtres
les calculs tous bien et calcule tous
très différemment des joueurs amateurs
en fait je dirais ça fait vraiment une
grosse différence
tu essayes d'aller jusqu'au bout quoi
non mais la rigueur dans le calcul est
complètement différente
mais je pense c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que tu as pas mal de gens de mon profil
qui arrête vraiment complètement en fait
moi je m'appelle dans mes catégories
jeunes
dont j'ai reparlé machin je vais pas
dire de nombre parce que je veux pas les
emmerder sur un live mais j'ai reparlé
il y a pas longtemps tu étais aussi dans
les meilleurs vins vraiment même plus ou
moins même profil que moi en fait ils
ont vraiment genre complètement arrêté
pareil en fait
il joue juste plus
tu en as pas mal qui font ça quand même
tu peux pas juste reprendre à moitié en
fait
peut-être un jour qui sait quand je
serai vieux et que je pourrais vraiment
plus calculer ça passera
voilà la partie tiens que j'avais en
tête finalement d'attaque qui était
sympa c'est ça
ok voilà
bon on la fera en vidéo si tu veux
magnifique oui
il avait gagné
[Musique]
non mais il avait raison il a raison en
fait je retasse mais en fait ça dépend
quel est ton ta mission en tant
qu'entraîneur si le but c'est que enfin
ce que vous êtes tout à l'heure si le
but c'est de faire jouer des joueurs et
de les monter au plus haut niveau
possible tu dois être le plus exigeant
possible si c'est des gens qui veulent
juste un peu mieux jouer un peu mieux
comprendre prendre plaisir mieux jouer
leurs ouvertures à comprendre certains
concepts tu vas pas les pousser comme
des fous tu es cool tu es tranquille
c'est pas grave ils prennent le temps
qu'il faut ils font pas leurs exercices
c'est pas un souci mais ça dépend soit
tu veux le niveau tu veux des titres tu
veux des trucs bah tu te bouges soit tu
es là c'est pour le plaisir bah on y va
tranquille et on avance au rythme on
peut et on va pas non plus vous pourrir
quoi enfin bon voilà si c'est un
entraîneur d'être intelligent par
rapport à la situation et aux objectifs
celle comme lui comme élève il aurait
quand même dû comprendre
tu sais il n'a au finesse intellectuelle
j'ai toujours su mais et puis d'ailleurs
après c'est peut-être nous qui avons mal
enfin Régis c'est pas le mot mais je
veux dire on avait le droit d'être
exigeant et de voir si c'est quand même
un jeu et en fait c'est juste c'était
trop la vie ou trop je sais pas
non mais ça aurait pu passer avec l'âge
quand même mais non
c'est ancré dans le cerveau et tu peux
plus enlever jouer une partie du jeu
d'échec non mais en plus je suis même
pas content de gagner si j'ai joué des
coups à l'intuition je vais en longue
ça sert à quoi en fait
si tu as gagné une partie on joue un
truc au hasard qui passe en sorte
pourquoi c'est con quoi
bah en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas de bol
non mais le problème c'est que même très
souvent c'est même pas fait je suis
beaucoup trop dégoûté de perdre par
rapport à ce que je suis content de
gagner même en journée en fait
gagner c'est plus un soulagement limite
c'est l'heure normal j'ai fait mon
boulot j'ai fait mon truc il n'y a pas
de grandes joie enfin trop rarement en
fait j'ai déjà eu des joies quand même
quand c'était des gros trucs
me dire ok c'est cool c'est plaisir mais
souvent c'est beaucoup plus
c'est plus mal de perdre quoi donc c'est
dommage qui est pas injuste équilibre
que ce soit aussi content quand tu
gagnes que dégoûté quand tu perds et qui
dit de l'autre tu gagnes plus souvent tu
es plus souvent content mais en fait
non mais ça me saoule de perdre mais je
sais pas genre
il est un peu dans le même problème
[Musique]
et puis bon il y a rien de tel pour
m'énerver que des trucs où tu domines la
position où tu as plus calculer bah une
des dernières faits sur la chaîne dans
le blackmart rappelle que j'avais joué
j'étais hyper énervé pendant la partie
que tout d'un coup le truc devienne dur
alors que j'ai calculé 10 fois plus et
que par hasard il y a un truc à la con
pratique qui fait que c'est compliqué et
de devoir regagner la partie une
deuxième fois voilà la demande
adversaire était il est assez sympa
parce que je le connais depuis que
j'étais enfant et il était enfin je sais
pas il était genre 2100 quoi et tu vas
analyser après la partie et tu vois que
tu as vu 56 de plus mais genre mais
vraiment net pour plus loin
et qu'en fait dans tous les cas même si
tu étais gagné en même si tout et tout
tu as un truc de contre jeu et d'un
point de vue pratique ça reste plus dur
à jouer pour toi même si c'est gagnant
et ça je trouve ça tellement injuste
dans ce jeu ça me rend fou à chaque fois
ouais
ça fait n'importe quoi avec une Torah J5
ça c'est révisé ouais
et je me rappelle que dans cette partie
il y avait une variante hyper critique
au début où j'avais calculé 20 minutes
et je montre à mon adversaire le truc
il est surpris que tu as regardé quoi
et en fait il m'a dit non mais j'avais
arrêté cette variante après deux coups
en fait j'avais pas compris pourquoi il
avait réfléchi lui 40 minutes parce
qu'il m'a rien montré de ce qui est
calcule
un truc à l'intuition et c'est marrant
parce que en fait quand il a arrêté moi
je sais pas j'ai vraiment calculé entre
9 et 10 coups quoi j'étais hyper long et
à la fin je monte le truc et tout et je
oui bon là je pense j'ai des chances de
gains je suis un peu mieux bon je suis
au petit dernier nul mais ça joue et il
me regarde mais genre avec des yeux
genre en mode mais enfin qui non en fait
moi j'ai juste arrêté là je me dis que
ça devait pas aller
ouais enfin
hyper sympa et tout qui est 2100 que je
voyais quand j'étais gamin et tout qui
me mettait 21 50 et en plus dans les
années 80 donc tu vois c'est un bonjour
quoi mais juste ouais c'est amateur quoi
c'est tapas
on t'a pas pourri la vie avec cette
exigence que tu dois avoir et du coup tu
peux t'arrêter de calculer une variante
juste parce que tu sens que ça va pas
enfin nous aussi on le fait des fois
mais là c'était vraiment très critique
en fait
et surtout pas passer 40 minutes du coup
si c'est pour pas calculer enfin on peut
importe mais du coup je sentais qu'il
aille plus kiffer la partie que moi
alors que bon il avait perdu il était
quand même content de la partie contre
moi enfin du terreau de jouer contre moi
il se fait un peu la chaîne machin était
content et alors que moi j'ai gagné la
partie et même encore aujourd'hui trois
ans après je te raconte je suis encore
énervé
mais c'est fou en fait
pourquoi
pourquoi tu as encore énervé
bon après c'est pour la partie elles
prennent une fois que c'est facile
mais c'est le fait que le jeu soit comme
ça qui m'énerve en fait
du contrôle
mais c'est ce qui met en PLS comme guéri
comme ça et tout qui arrive pas du tout
à le contrôler quoi
ils sont mille fois plus fort que nous
en se compare pas à eux sur le plan
chicien mais c'est le même la même
maladie
alors que Hikaru par exemple
ils sont souvent plus du côté des gens
qui ont contre jeu aussi
ils se mettent pas en PLS quand ils
l'ont pas et ils l'ont souvent eux-mêmes
ouais
mais cette partie
on va voir il a bouffé un petit rond est
contente pour les Noirs alors que
peut-être qu'elle surestime le pion de
plus
c'est quand même une petite jauge quoi
donc du coup
plus de mal à peut-être
plus doué que actuellement il n'y a que
Magnus je dirais pas ça il y a peut-être
d'une époux ambulant il y a peut-être du
carwana il y a peut-être du digne
etc des fois tu as des gens très doués
qui justement stoppe parce que ils ont
pas assez travaillé ou quoi
mais Naka c'est très fort mais c'est
fort
rognon aussi
dur de comparer après
ils ont tous quand même un bon petit
talent quand même pour notre arrivée là
et ils ont travaillé
mais c'est des gens qui auraient été
plus forts que nous sans rien [ __ ] en
fait c'est ça qui est impressionnant
enfin sans rien [ __ ] façon de parler
oui votre aurait pu un peu lever elle
avait déjà 2006 je sais pas 15-16 ans
quoi donc
il aurait pu arrêter de travailler à ce
moment-là il arrête pas trop baisser
quoi
tellement fort
qu'ils ont besoin d'en savoir beaucoup
moins pour bien jouer
s'est-il vraiment préparé pour les
candidats et les Grands Prix ouais ouais
il avait plein d'idées dans les
ouvertures
oui se préparer après tu vois je sais
pas quel point enfin je sais pas comment
dire moi mais il s'est préparé enfin tu
peux pas les Grands Prix en faisant que
de la merde ça existe pas et un peu de
réussite aussi faut dire mais
il a plutôt bien joué sa place n'était
pas volé c'est pas juste la chance à
chaque tour c'est non c'est bien
absolument pas volé évidemment mais je
veux dire qu'il a pas survolé non plus
les Grands Prix ce que je voulais dire
non mais
c'est pas il a pas gagné les Grands Prix
en sifflotant
c'est dur à faire ça genre même Carlson
radio
non non mais juste je pensais vraiment
spécifiquement la partie contre ici
piano qui doit perdre 100 fois et en
fait ça le fait instantanément
mais
c'était pas facile la française oui mais
genre celle contre les la dernière du
groupe 5 ans
il trouve un il a joué sur sa force de
bien défendre oui oui mais je veux dire
que il était vraiment à un coup et si
piano de complètement l'éliminer quoi
une énorme résistance mais en fait ça
dépend public enfin si explique aux
joueurs
[Musique]
ça lui a fait mal
j'espère pour lui que il reviendra oui
c'est un beau talent de toute façon il
est toujours jeune donc au pire c'est
une petite pause dans la progression
mais des fois on nous a dit ça tu peux
stopper ta progression et puis c'est la
vie il restera 2007 ce qui est déjà très
honorable mais pas dit qu'il gagne 50
points 100 points ou quoi
je pense que ça va être dur donc tu
bloques là à cet âge-là
pendant longtemps comme il est en train
de le faire
tu entraîne ici piano je crois que
c'était donc c'est ça
ouais prolon il était en train de
que j'ai connu toute ma vie que j'ai
toujours lu j'ai jamais croisé une fois
dans aucun tournoi
de défendre
il est hyper connu tout le monde connaît
son nom
et je l'ai juste jamais croisé aucun
tournoi enfin
c'est fou quoi
il est mort il part jeune 56 ans
j'aurais pensé
en 97
un peu mais
il était 25 80 quand même
ce qui est dans les années 80 était pas
mal peut-être qu'il a pas joué depuis 94
en fait
non mais c'est sûr
tu es pas trop nul quoi par contre
c'était les Slaves à l'ancien
[Musique]
pour essayer de voir j'ai jamais vu une
de ces parties en fait c'est terrible
alors qu'il est vraiment très connu
mettre sur impression que je vais mater
avec les lents dans ces positions enfin
j'en suis toujours absolument convaincu
et achètent très souvent je m'atte pas
et je suis toujours aussi surpris c'est
pas facile quoi
mais c'était j'ai un biais cognitif dans
ce truc là et je le sais mais ça
m'empêche pas de tout le temps être
choqué quoi
quel logiciel tu utilises pour trouver
les parties logiciels et laquelle il a
juste utilisé moteur de recherche tu
tapes le nom de la personne tu veux
chercher et ta chaise games
sur le site
et voilà donc là où l'autre marche après
si tu as de chez base c'est un truc en
dur sur mon ordi et cheese Games c'est
un peu sur internet quoi ça va ou tu as
voilà 365s a priori qui marche aussi
donc c'est des sites pas obligé d'avoir
un logiciel
mais du coup
entraîneur connu
et on en sait absolument gratuits
alors chez moi pas trop comment ça
marche mais sûrement bien sûr
que tu tapes juste dans Google les deux
joueurs quand tu te rappelles d'une
partie
généralement la partie elle sort c'est
des parties connues elle sort plus ou
moins en premier
probablement d'origine arménienne je
pense j'espère pas dire de bêtises
il fait partie de ces grands entraîneurs
clairement ça a affecté et si Piennes
quoi de perdre
son coach
bah des fois ok tu pourras juste un
coach coach et puis tu peux avoir si le
coach qui est en mode un peu montant
aussi qui est ta compagne qui fait plein
de choses
et donc forcément tu es touché quoi
parce que c'est plus qu'un simple mec
qui te fait bouger des bouts de bois
quoi c'est quelqu'un qui t'attend
vraiment dans ta vie etc quoi
grand entraîneur
mon souhait va réussir à faire nul je
pense parti pour la et champion de plus
à mon avis il veut tout échanger pas
pour gagner la finale de pion mais pour
faire nul dans la finale de pion
ben oui complètement enfin c'est quand
même
il est morte en 2021
ta grande chaîne du temps on a vu une
Épona nepo Naka en car non c'était une
époque c'était une akadouda pardon
qui avait un tableau plutôt ouvert hors
d'Internet ce qui a joué c'est vu en qui
était repêché qu'il a dominé et il a un
peu il a gagné le match contre guéri
vraiment contre le cours du match
mais bon
les cadeaux surtout parce que guérilla a
vraiment fait des cadeaux
je pense qu'il faut faire juste
c'est tellement le scénario de toutes
mes parties dans cette structure je
pense que je vais faire mal et c'est un
coup j'ai plus de pièces quoi
mais là je suis encore très confiant là
j'ai encore les cases noirs autour du
roi donc là ça va encore là je suis
encore à deux doigts de maths mais là
généralement je dirais bon heureusement
que j'ai le pion H4 et tout ce que c'est
un peu plus compliqué que prévu quoi
mais je reste très confiant généralement
et quelques trucs
[Musique]
prendre des trois temps après
mais bon
en maths
en tout cas si sogagne le tournoi est
déjà terminé exactement exactement ça
peut parce que de toute façon autant
faire au lit pour pour ça
après gagner les deux dernières blancs
noirs ça va quand même être compliqué
complètement
je reviens OK
donc ouais
en fait en gros donc pour dire
ça rien a mis sa batterie fout des trois
dame 4 en direction du roi adverse donc
il a provoqué le coup G6 qui bloque les
cases blanches et en contrepartie so il
est pas trop le choix il devait faire en
contrepartie donc ça a fait Billy casse
noir donc maintenant les blancs vont
essayer de faire un plan plutôt case
noir pour se rapprocher donc essayer de
mettre la dame en H6
après s'il peut mettre un fond F6 pour
faire dame G7 bah ça sera parfait pour
eux évidemment il va pas le laisser
faire mais la dommage 6 c'est dur de
l'enlever et puis le support du kij5 et
l'autre plan serait de faire H5 pion H6
et notamment F6 slash
5h à condition de glisser une tour donc
ça c'est les plans d'attaque des blancs
arrivent à réaliser tout ça et sauf il
va
essayer d'empêcher quoi donc pas laisser
que ça se passe si facilement
le truc c'est qu'effectivement ça prend
un peu de temps pour les blancs donc je
me dis que peut-être prendre des trois
et les mines de pièces et bah c'est ce
qui est en train de faire c'est pas mal
donc bon dame trans pas logique s'il y a
pas de découverte avec le footcas blanc
puisqu'il y a qui allait prendre un donc
on peut pas donc dame prend 3 ça semble
logique parce qu'en plus ça redirige la
dame en direction de H6 après peut-être
qu'ils sont froid donc ça a l'air d'être
un coup absolument horrible visuellement
mais au moins ça ouvre la Tour Eiffel
tu voulais reprendre de F ouais je pense
comme il a pas repris tempo qu'il est
sans tête mais c'est quand même
exactement
après une fois que tu vas commencer à te
changer les tours et qui va rester plus
que les pièces mineures et le fou pour
couvrir les cases noires il va suffire
on a réussi à faire avec un Insee damage
6 puis kg 5 réussir à récuperer
peut-être faire damage 6 ou F4 qui est
G5 reprendre du Fou aller vers F6 et
mater ça ça peut être un plan
mais bon ce sera quand même dur s'il
faudra pas se prendre à ce moment là
après foule que le four reprenne en G5
un dam prend E5 et dames G7 qui
viendrait tout couvrir avec deux pions
de plus ah non c'est vraiment dur de
faire mat
pas simple
alors que je travaille complètement sûr
que je suis gagnant
à chaque fois je regarde la liste de
parties encore raté un truc quoi
[Musique]
non mais après ça reste plus simple à
jouer en pratique quand on voit tes
pièces et à l'autre de trouver ses
défenses
là le problème c'est que ça allait trop
quand même en face
on va donc il a pas appris en Détroit
bon écoute
il donne
une option de faire plus tard
[Musique]
je pense que plutôt faire tourner 8 et
aller carrément échanger massivement en
Détroit c'est vrai qu'il y a plus de
tours tu crains plus un plan comme kg 5
et je prends g et colonnage
6 comme un plot et c'est tout donc tu as
besoin d'une tour avec les Blancs quand
même tu craques
le dernier possible c'est de faire
damage 6 fois F4 fougères
pour pouvoir reprendre du cavalier ou
s'il faut s'en va parfois
c'est que s'il y a plus de temps fuite
tu te fais bloquer la dame
donc si tu as ni celui-là nickel j'ai 5
avec H3 qui marche
problème ça pourrait
Fiat en disant je crois que je prends du
fou il te fera fouet fit à ce moment-là
dame G5 il te reviendra il veut te faire
un chantage au pire il a peut-être mieux
à faire mais vu la situation du match
ça glisse du Fongecif ouais mais tu vois
pas assez loin il peut te prendre de
deux manières différentes et tu vois
souvent on donne un fou c'est soit
poursuivre avec kg 5 échecs etc le
service connu le H7 soit faut enlever
deux pions
un moment donné en fait la dame elle
court et du couvre toutes les cases très
facilement
ce serait pas une très très bonne idée
la psychologiquement c'est dur aussi
pour Sarine dans le sens où tu fais tu
tends pas quand même largement
après écoute il faut tenter après il
joue contre un mec plus fort que lui de
toute façon c'est c'est
comme ça donc des fois tu fais tout ce
que tu peux puis ça joue mis en face et
non mais je veux dire que tu es mené
deux points tu sens que le mec est plus
fort tu as ton attaque tu t'en parles
bon ça devient dur dans la tête à quoi
la jauge ça fera un petit peu mais
logiquement parce que du coup la chose
elle veut prendre maintenant des 8 en
des trois pardon et mettre la tour en D8
et du coup on a gagné un peu le tempo
qu'on voulait gagner après son plan
c'est jaillir vers F6
oui
c'est bien joué hein
en fait moi aussi
ah ça donne
de combien des lots entre eux bon plus
ou moins 100 points de vrais élo je veux
dire
[Musique]
dans le 3 pour retourner vers H6 et
d'avoir donné le passage au cavalier
je pense que ça me Troie la jauge est
plus affolée parce qu'en fait je crois
que la jauge elle voit dame 3 tours des
4 cavaliers 4 cavaliers C4 d'af4
là-dessus j'ai l'impression que le
problème c'est qu'il y a dames 5
[Musique]
mais non
et tu reprends des cartes il faut
prendre c'est juste mais ok ça c'est pas
ah et
en fait tu fais de tout reprendre
cavalier cavalier de prendre de la dame
oui et là il y a jamais mais en fait
donc là tu fais Dame des 8 et tu déloges
ça peut ne pas être trouvé bon lui il
joue pour qu'il y ait des quatre qui est
5 il se revient vers les cases pour
tenir loin
les cavaliers
mais c'était vraiment dur
juste cavalier 4 qui a été 4
cavalier 7 il ferme
pour l'instant mais ça nous a assez de
temps pour faire calife 5 et compagnie
et sur cavalieux 4 qui a été 4 damage 6
pour le faire dans l'autre sens il veut
cavalier F5 et cavalier F6 vous prend
puis on prend la dame tombe en premier
je pense que c'est ce qu'il veut non
mais c'est sûr qu'il va faire c'est sûr
je sais pas on n'est jamais sûr de rien
mais qui a eu des quatre ça semble
clairement être son idée
[Musique]
c'est bien défendu quand même non mais
pour l'instant logique de part et
d'autre
plus que 3 10 fournir le Sarine
faire attention soit l'air serein ouais
mais en fait c'est genre de position tu
as le match c'est 3 2 dans le match tu
es peut-être beaucoup moins serein c'est
ce dont parler hier les deux points de
matelas je dis au pire même si je
faisais une gaffe j'ai encore un point
d'avant je joue au blanc enfin ça te
donne quand même une sérénité dans ce
genre de position où tu sais que tu es
mieux et tu sais qu'une gaffe te coûte
pas le match tu as la même position à 4
4 dans l'Armageddon bon
on verra
à plus de points le match est rempli
alors c'est pas complètement plié mais
oui enfin c'est en fait c'est surtout
les deux points et la différence de
niveau c'est que si c'était Sarine qui
menait deux points on a cette position
là il reste deux parties derrière je te
dirai oui bon c'est plié on va quand
même un peu jouer hein mais
ici le truc c'est que c'est les deux
points ils sont dans les griffes du chat
le chat qui fait mal
ça peut proposer nul à tout moment là
côté Wesley pour troll une petite nulle
pour avoir une partie de plus là c'est
roi G7 évidemment je pense
ouais c'est terrible cavalier en F5 qui
va blinder qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué
Wesley c'est un modèle hein
un modèle de défense
après c'est sûr qu'on va attendre Ikaru
au tour précédent qui a un peu un profil
à la Sarine bon de loin mais juste 150
points l'autre plus
c'est vrai que ça sentait bon quand même
je sais pas à t'abattu Nadal en demi et
en finale bon tu joues Kareno gusta à
Roland Garros ouais ouais ça fait quand
même plus plaisir
tu dis si c'est pas assez contrat Kareno
gusta en fond de court
on devrait tenir quand même un peu
tremblant finalement
ok oui
non il joue il trouve quand même un truc
il veut H5 G4 je pense ouais bon je
ferai quand de base parce que j'ai une
stabiliser mon
programme
c'est pas fini hein
il a trouvé un vrai un vrai challenge
après peut-être tu fais tout reprendre
un tour
tu enlèves des trucs comme ça si tu as
plus d'avancer ça tu pourras prendre F6
enfin
il va décaler d'ailleurs mais bon du
coup ça a ton avantage quand même tu as
échangé les têtes à des tours des quatre
à ce moment-là et compagnie
la suite après il peut dans tes roches 2
mais bon
ça va pas passer
relativement loin de menacer 4
et quelques coups
mécaniquement puis on prend d'un point
F4 c'est bien joué aussi soit défendre
le fou sur l'enlever de là
ou enlever le cavalier mais du coup on
aimait bien fêter le fond puis ça a pas
trop de cases si tu vas quelque part
c'est H2
mais clairement c'est une concession
d'aller en âge de tu te bloques le roi
tu te remets dans ton D8 qui menacera
mat
et en plus une fois une fois que tu
donnes un peu plus de fous F6 ouais donc
il y a eu 4 je trouve bien joué aussi
il recule mais pour revenir quoi
reculer pour mieux sauter
le pion de 5 il faut G5
et revenir quand même une fois un moment
tu as envie de tout échanger
[Musique]
on va essayer qui a l'air hyper
tranquille hyper serein
après ouais petit
truc comme ça
en tout cas ça calcule
et sur cavalier prend puis on prend faut
prendre
ok bien joué
extrêmement confiance pour les noirs
puis on prend des 6 vous prend des 6
dames des trois faut prendre H2S
c'est juste que nous on va pas avoir
parce qu'on est deux cons mais
d'ailleurs ils ont tous les deux
si on prend Tam G7 8mg 8 ouais
mais peut-être que tu as même un foyer
qui va rouler beaucoup de merde comme ça
c'est pas trop grand tu vois les gens
qui disent choquent non c'est pas un
choc de NiAl
[Musique]
on aurait tous fait pareil enfin moi
j'aurais fait exactement la même chose
que lui là de toute façon et puis en
plus tu as pas spécialement envie je
vais te dire d'en rejouer une de plus si
tu fais nul
qui couvre ciao ça va se finir là
normalement
et oui
finale express
et bravo à lui il a retrouvé du poil de
la bête
voilà
ces derniers temps
noir il a su être très très solide quand
on accueille le faire fertile des et la
finale entièrement maîtrisée
et donc il va gagner la coquette somme
de quoi 200000
[Musique]
bien mérité il a été le meilleur joueur
sur ce tournoi sur cette phase
déjà qu'on travaille
très facilement
voilà si tu fais de ferme ta main tu
mets le rends H6 dame 6 proposer
de se prendre ma tante de enfin c'est
pas maths encore toi
et ça arrive à faire un bon tournoi oui
oui il a fait un bon tournoi
il pourrait être il pourrait être
content de son tournoi quand même
juste pas tomber quoi en fait
il était plutôt dominé contre
un c'est comme ça
et quand ça Rinne est un peu en dessous
mais plus réaliste
des trucs de ouf mais il assure il va
gagner quand il fallait et voilà bon
ouais même là la finale
c'est pas trop mal ce qu'il a même fait
mais bon
c'est sûr qu'il l'emporte dans une
journée qui est derrière dernière
journée courte finalement
hier il a déjà pris le lit de deux
points et il fallait tenter quelque
chose aujourd'hui il a tenté de gagner
dans les deux premières bah écoute il
est pas arrivé et moi Rousseau c'est
comme ça après je la finale dure moins
longtemps que prévu c'est pas c'est pas
grave en soi
on a eu du spectacle surtout dans la
demi-finale nakasso en fait et la
dernière partie au final c'était le
match le plus serré enfin
je sais pas j'ai pas eu la même tension
en fait Sonaca c'était vraiment le match
qui restera dans
ton se rappellera dans cette compétition
c'était la finale la réelle finale avant
l'heure
qui a été qui a été gagné par
par Wesley
et on sentait bien de toute façon que
que Wesley contre contre guérisse aurait
été plus compliqué parce que c'était
deux joueurs très solide ça aurait pu
faire beaucoup de nuls et ça aurait pu
se jouer sur un coup de dés entre
guillemets
mais là
c'était trop facile en fait
ouais trop facile pour ce haut qui est
excellent bien joué et ben écoute on
peut dire bravo à lui
et quoi d'autre bien sûr qu'on peut lui
dire bravo je suis pas une question de
fermeture on se retrouve pour le
speechasse qui est une belle compète qui
sera plus
pêchu je pense dans le rythme bah ouais
il y aura déjà plus de rythme et puis
même et le plateau le plateau et c'est
surtout le plateau parce que là tu fais
une finale même saut Carlsen c'est quand
même pas la même chose sans vouloir
meilleur plateau plus de rythme ça sera
bien après bon on serait tenté de chez
SCOM ici ça reste intéressant cette
formule du sport après peut-être
réfléchir un peu le formal enfin mais
bon ils sont ils sont sur la voie
d'essayer un nouveau format et on verra
faut quand même les encourager
bah oui il faut qu'ils essayent de
trouver
la bonne carburation quoi et un moyen
d'avoir un plateau
plus plus fourni ouais je pense c'est
surtout le plateau au final qui a une
nuit
à l'événement en fait
après
voilà bon je vais aller me diriger
tranquillement vers le match de synthé
essayer de prendre des points à Metz ce
soir
bon courage ça a déjà commencé non non
c'est large j'aurais pu avoir une petite
partie de plus ça aurait été possible il
y a pas de problème
allez les verts j'ai envie de dire et
puis moi je vais aller faire quelques
petits Blitz donc on se retrouve très
bientôt les amis et puis et puis on va
espérer pour toi une victoire de santé
merci encore mon frère pour pour ce
tournoi et à très bientôt ciao ciao